Speaker 1: All right. Let's look at a couple
other interesting clips. There was an event
with Christian supporters of Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker. Now,
Herschel Walker claims to be pro-life. He
claims that abortion is murder. He claims
no exceptions for the woman, whether it's rape,
incest or health or none, no exceptions ever.
And he has now been credibly accused of
urging and paying for an abortion for a woman
with whom he allegedly already had another
child. And the right wingers and the Christians,
you would think that they would say, wow,
well, this guy really isn't for us. Instead,
they held a prayer for Herschel and his wife.
They apparently believe that these attacks are
coming from the devil. They rebuke the devil.
This is utter insanity. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: In the fight of his life. Oh, my
God. Amen. And we call forth your ministering
angels. Yeah. And we ask you to dupe the devil.
Speaker 1: And it's the devil's fault,
not Herschel.
Speaker 3: Walker's
saint will not get the victory. Now
we know whatever the results of this
election, Herschel wins. Right. He's
a winner. We are more than one life.
Speaker 1: Hey, you know, maybe if
these values are so important to you,
Christian supporters of Herschel Walker maybe
focus on the fact that he lied to you about his
view on abortion rather than blaming the devil.
Speaker 3: All right. So we thank you that we can
support our fellow conquer your brother, our
friend. You are the one that we are praying for
today. We lift up his wife, Jill, here, and they
matter right here for 10 minutes and tell her,
yes, we know that her heart is sensitive to all
of these and all the things the enemy will dredge
up and throw against God make her stronger.
Speaker 1: This is this is not a satire.
This is real. I hope people understand.
Speaker 3: Her with spiritual resolve. Yes.
The backbone of Holy Ghost. Yes. And they will
be stronger than it's ever been before. Yes.
Speaker 1: So they have renewed faith in Herschel
Walker. These are hipper Christians, hypocritical
Christians. This wasn't the work of the devil.
This was Herschel Walker, his own doing. And
Herschel Walker's own lying and dishonesty.
And, by the way, praying for the guy. After
we learned not only about this entire abortion
fiasco, but his ex-wife and son had to move six
times in six years due to the alleged acts of
domestic violence from Herschel Walker against
his family. And they're praying for Herschel.
What's Christian about that? And again, only if
you're so diluted and also, by the way, willing to
suspend disbelief in a way where you say none of
this stuff is true. What's true is that the
devil, Satan, apparently sent by Democrats,
Democrats have Satan on a hotline, apparently send
them in any time. That's who's to blame here. This
really is sort of like the cherry on top where
there is no reasoning with these people. Now,
why do I think the polling continues to shift
away from Walker? If his supporters are like
this. They're not all like this. There are more
casual Republicans in Georgia who they don't like.
WARNOCK But after this, they're not going to vote
for WALKER Independents as well. And that's why I
believe that the next round of polling that we
get, we'll probably know it by Monday, Tuesday
after the Monday holiday. I believe that Walker
will be even more underwater than he already is.